what is the chi-square test and how is
the chi-square test calculated that's
what we will discuss in this video let's
start with the first question what is
the chi-square test the chi-square test
is a hypothesis test that is used when
you want to determine if there is a
relationship between two categorical
variables what are categorical variables
again categorical variables are for
example gender with the categories male
and female
the preferred newspaper with the
categories USA Today The Wall Street
Journal the New York Times and so on or
the highest educational level with the
categories without graduation College
bachelor's degree master's degree
so gender preferred newspaper and
highest educational level are all
categorical variables for example no
categorical variables are the weight of
a person the salary of a person or the
power consumption
if we now have two categorical variables
and we want to test whether there is a
relationship we use a chi-square test
for example is there a relationship
between gender and the preferred
newspaper we have two categorical
variables so we use a chi-square test
another example is the red relationship
between preferred newspaper and highest
educational level here again we have two
categorical variables so we use a
chi-square test
however there are two things to note
first the Assumption for the chi-square
test is that the expected frequencies
per cell are greater than five we'll go
over what that means in a moment
second the chi-square test uses only the
categories and not the rankings however
in the case of the highest educational
level there is a ranking of categories
if you want to account for rankings
check out our tutorials on Spearman
correlation man with new test or
classical Wallis test
but how do we calculate the chi-square
test let's go through that with an
example we would like to investigate
whether gender has an influence on the
preferred newspaper so our question is
is there a relationship between gender
and the preferred newspaper our null
hypothesis is there is no relationship
between gender and the preferred
newspaper and our alternative hypothesis
is there is a relationship between
gender and the preferred newspaper so
first we create a questionnaire that
asks about gender and the preferred
newspaper we will then send out the
questionnaire the results of the survey
are displayed in a table in this table
we see one respondent in each row
the first respondent is male and stated
New York Post the second respondent is
female and stated USA Today
we can now copy this table into a
statistics software like datadab datadab
then gives us the so-called contingency
table in this table you can see the
variable newspaper and the variable
gender the number of times each
combination occurs is plotted in the
cells for example in this survey There
are 16 people who stated New York Post
and mail
or 13 people who stated female and New
York Post now we want to know if gender
has an influence on the preferred
newspaper or put another way is there a
relationship between gender and the
preferred newspaper now to answer this
question we use the chi-square test
there are two ways we can calculate the
chi-square test either we use a
statistical software like data tab or we
calculate the chi-square test by hand we
start with the uncomplicated variant and
use data tab if you like you can load
the sample data set for calculation you
can find the link in the video
description to calculate a chi-square
test online simply copy your own data
into this table or use the link to load
this data set
then the variables gender and newspaper
appear here below
now we click on hypothesis test here you
will find a variety of tests and data
tab will help you to choose the right
one
for example if we click on gender and
newspaper the chi-square test will be
automatically calculated
now we get the results for the
chi-square test above we see the
contingency table for the variables
gender and newspaper the contingency
table shows us how often the respective
combinations occur in our survey female
and USA Today for example occurs six
times in the second table we can see
what the contingency table should
actually look like if the two variables
were perfectly independent that is if
gender had no influence on the preferred
newspaper here it is important to note
that all of the frequencies should be
larger than 5 so that the assumptions of
the chi-square test are fulfilled but
this is the case here the chi-squareth
has now Compares this table with that
table and here we see the results
the p-value is
0.91 which is much higher than our
significance level of
0.05 and therefore we keep the null
hypothesis if you don't know exactly how
to interpret the results just click on
summary in words
a chi-square test was performed between
gender and newspaper all expected cell
frequencies were greater than 5 thus the
assumptions for the chi-square test were
met there was no statistically
significant relationship between gender
and newspaper this results in the
p-value of
0.918 which is above the defined
significance level of 5 the chi-square
test is therefore not significant and
the null hypothesis is not rejected if
you're unsure what exactly the p-value
means just watch our video about the
p-value and now we come to the question
how to calculate the chi-square test by
hand and we go through the formulas
needed don't worry it's not difficult
we need the contingency table with the
observed frequencies the contingency
table with the expected frequencies that
is those frequencies that would occur
with perfectly independent variables
you can find how to calculate the
expected frequencies on data tab in the
tutorial on the chi-square test
we can now calculate the chi-square with
this formula the index K stands for the
respective cell okay is the observed
frequency e k is the expected frequency
so we get
six minus
6.08 squared divided by 6.08 plus the
next cell
7 minus 6.92 squared divided by 6.92
if we do this for all cells and sum them
up we get a chi-square of 0.504
so this results in a chi-square value of
0.504 now we would like to calculate the
critical chi-square value what do we
need it for if you use a statistical
software we simply get a p-value
displayed if the value is smaller than
the significance level for example 0.05
the null hypothesis is rejected
otherwise not in our example case the
null hypothesis is not rejected by hand
however you can't really calculate the
p-value therefore you read off in a
table which chi-square value you would
get with a p-value of 0.05 this
chi-square value is called the critical
chi-square value in order to calculate
the critical chi-square value we need
the degrees of freedom these are
obtained by taking the number of rows
minus one times the number of columns
minus one we have four rows and two
columns therefore we get three times one
and thus 3 degrees of freedom now let's
take a look at the table of critical
chi-square values you can find this
table on data tab the link is in the
video description we select a
significance level of 0.05 and have
three degrees of freedom therefore our
critical chi-square value is
7.815 the critical task Square value of
7.815 is larger than our calculated
chi-square value of 0.504
thus the null hypothesis is retained
thanks for watching and I hope to see
you next time